today's topic i got a little bit
triggered by this one my man was bugging
if you read the title right now
you could kind of understand why okay
let me say this
for the purposes conversation when
people label somebody a quitter
right it's not a neutral thing it's a
negative thing
if you label someone a quitter you're
basically calling them a coward yeah or
someone who basically gives up yeah
right but they don't have
any backbone no character that's what it
is yeah all right
so this is the story about simone she
quit like she literally quit
because because of her mental health
issue right
so then that says that she's a quitter
first and foremost
she's not a hero for doing that she quit
let me ask you so so my question is
they're on deployment they're in
afghanistan they're dealing with mental
health issues they say i need to go back
i'm not well in the head
are you going to call that veteran a
quitter
at that point yeah because you're not
completing the mission you have reasons
of quitting
which are your ptsd and all of these
things but you have
quit you've thrown in the towel and said
whatever is overcoming me in my head
can make me continue if i break my leg
during a a an olympic track meet
and i can't break a leg though no no no
no no because because they can't go on
that's what they're saying i can't go on
i'm but not because of your leg if you
get injured if you get
injured because of the sport right like
let's say lebron for some people the
injury
an injury is only physical for a lot of
people for the basis of people
he got injured if you're not mentally
there
your body's still there one of your
biggest biggest organs
in anything is your head where your
heads at
you could have all your limbs and if
your hair's not there you're not gonna
be able to perform
yeah you know you ever heard about
cracking under the pressure that's what
it is
but to a lot of people injuring breaking
a leg
and bringing your mantle and you broke
your leg mental
meh that attitude is exactly what led to
so many people not being taken seriously
for ptsd for decades yeah of course i
mean it wasn't even a thing for most
folks they didn't take it seriously
you could have ptsd went to the doctor
in the military and they'd be like
no to this day i mean to this day they
still send people to this day if you
feel like your ptsd is not severe enough
just get back out there
it's like yeah so it's a very
clear indication of how people view
mental health issues versus physical
issues
because one is visible the other one's
in your head so people are ready to
doubt you
not knowing the one in the head is just
as common
you know whether it be depression or all
these issues or
you know self-deletions just as common
but they don't
believe it because they can't see it and
so they downplay it
and as a result people have to suffer
and one of the comments i saw
someone said yeah but she did the
interview after she was fine
bro remember uh was it robin williams
it was happy all the time they always
think everyone's happy
all everybody that deleted themselves i
can't believe
that he would take his life yeah because
when he had signs or when he had issues
he noticed he would have told people
about it they wouldn't have taken him
seriously exactly because of his mental
health that's because they're gonna
break a leg or something like that so
that's that's a lot of people that that
that deleted themselves were happy
you couldn't see that coming you're like
oh my god yep
right like let's say lebron james is
playing and he gets injured while
playing the sport right
and that makes sense you're not quitting
you're just literally being substituted
off
why doesn't he play with a broken leg if
you're getting injured while playing the
sports you're not quitting
you're seeing someone with ptsd okay who
can't function
should go into the field and if they
don't they're a quitter but if they
break their leg i don't think they'll
even be allowed to go do that
there's plenty of soldiers right now who
are out there and still doing
deployments and have ptsd and should not
be out there
i've seen unfit people who are mentally
unstable
stay in the military and you know what
they're a danger to other people
extremely like listen you know it's not
enough to just show up
that that's not coming through for your
team if you're compromised
you're a liability if you end up in a
[ __ ] up situation because your head's
not in the right place
you put us all at risk that's the way it
works
it's not quitting but that's someone
it's not quitting you
you the best thing you could do in some
situations is to remove yourself
because then you don't hold everyone
else back you don't want it to happen at
the ninth hour you don't want to have
but sometimes that's when it happens
because there's so much pressure and
there's so many goobers like this guy
who come out here and say you're a
quitter if you don't keep going that
people feel the need to ignore their
issues in order to persevere forward not
realizing that they're
actually hurting the people around them
go ahead but the thing that happened is
that people like that
often are not in those situations no
they're not in sports
they've never been a veteran they've
never met they've never been out there
so they don't know
they know what a ptsd is because of the
word but they don't really know what it
implies right yeah it's like the people
that are saying man you know what man
woman they can play the same sport
most of these people never been in the
fightings but most these people
don't even know don't even know and the
ones that are
in the sports are the ones that
advantages yeah it's always that
i'm gonna take it a step further take
take it
walk on how many people that you've
known
died from a broken leg
how many people do you know or you've
heard about that diaper from ptsd
oh yeah okay next step i'm not surprised
that this is coming from a black man
yes definitely i was about to go in
there yep you know what
take it away i wanted to say it and i
kept from saying it because i thought
you said you know what whatever let's
not do that or you would have an
argument for that but you know black
people mental health and black people
there's been something that you know we
don't talk about i don't understand
where it's coming from you have to
understand where it comes from
it comes from the fact that we couldn't
allow ourselves to get there
we couldn't allow ourselves to oh yeah
mental this and that we could we
we have to keep on going we'd have to
we'd have to keep on the fight and do
stuff to do
do stuff it didn't it did great but it
did a lot of bad too
because now not talking about mental
health not taking care of a mental
we are crippled and we live with that
and by living with someone that has
mental that never is never addressed
because that person still has to go on
it [ __ ] up the kids
in church no no let's let god let's pray
god
let's pray god he's gonna fix everything
no [ __ ]
god ain't gonna do [ __ ] about your
mental health he's not gonna do
something better with that there's
something that says you know there's
something to say
help yourself and god will help you
after that but people really put
themselves
and everything into god's hands and
stuff like that no you have to do
something about that
mental health just like breaking your
legs how come when you break your leg
you go to the doctor but your mental
health
you're gonna pray god so it's so it's
very downplayed in the black community
we don't talk about mental health
it's a very big taboo we never do that
we often think it's something that i
often heard
in the black community and mental health
that's why people [ __ ]
suicide self delete
anxiety burnout
why people [ __ ] because they couldn't
afford to do that but what happens when
you go home and someone is actually
burnt out
and goes back home they beat their wife
they beat their kids for no reason you
know we joke a lot about the in the
black community you know whenever we
want to talk about our [ __ ]
we talk about oh you ever get your ass
well yeah i had my ass whooped
but you had you there's there's been
some time where there's been some stress
that you had
your ass whooped for no reason we can
laugh about it
but let's think about it it comes from
somewhere stress
anxiety at work burn out we don't talk
about it enough
i i'm not i'm i when i saw a black dude
saying that i was like
yeah yeah it's a big problem
a lot of us are nurses and work in the
field of health
but we really take our health
second we're ready to cater to other
people
but we're not ready to take care of
ourselves a lot of people strive to be i
want to be a psychologist
i want to work in social studies i want
to be a nurse but when it comes to our
health we don't do it we cater to others
but we don't cater to us
and our people and we call that white
people stuff and stuff like that
that's very slave mentality
i said it what are you talking about
you're saying someone who is compromised
whether it's physically or mentally
should go do something that is dangerous
if they don't they're a quitter that is
what you said her mind wasn't hurt
she's playing a physical sport is what
i'm saying
even the phrase her mind wasn't hurt how
do you know
it's the arrogance of people of not
being in people's situations saying
but then that person self deletes and
like oh that's so sad oh i can't believe
it like
why would he do that because people like
this are ready to disbelieve you
or tell you what you're going through is
not real it's like turn on that person's
head
and they're not even known imagine
having that arrogance do you not see how
stupid that is
i'm not saying you got to inherently
believe them and go behind them but why
go out of your way to say that didn't
happen
that's what's weird to me i'll take a
step you don't have to you don't have to
see her
she's not a hero cool i agree whatever
we agree
but ain't like she has no character she
was faking it that's the weird part
but people have to believe that because
even despite the fact that there's no
proof
they'd rather just run with their
narrative and their bias she's playing a
physical sport
and something that's going on with her
can't make her play
on that certain day and you can't show
up that day
it's pretty much quitting you can't show
up that day because you can't
function do you understand what that
means but she's quit she's let down the
country
she she wasn't she was
focus on what i said yeah she can't
compete because she can't
function that doesn't label you a hero
at all
i didn't say that again listen to what i
said you called her quitter i didn't say
she was a hero that's a different thing
she can't function so she didn't compete
and you're saying she's a quitter so why
did she go there
when kevin durant was on that main stage
playing for the golden state warriors
with his ankle injury even though the
doctor said he shouldn't have
didn't his team pressure him to go back
on the field and he did go
yeah and he did go and what happened
what happened 12 minutes what happened
12 minutes
on the field huh he got injured again
kevin durant could have said no no no no
no no
no no once he gets injured again you're
like oh we could have said no
[ __ ] if you don't get your take all
your [ __ ] and get the [ __ ] out of here
what team doctors
i feel you team doctors
will do what's in the best interest of
the team even if it's at the risk of
your own health
kevin durant should have never been on
that nba final stage
everyone knows it everyone knows it
but due to the pressure that athletes
face
from their teammates from the media from
the public this man went out there and
compromised his health
and took away a year of his basketball
life because
other people said so and then he said he
could have said no
but if you would have said no you would
have labeled him a quitter no you you
can't
you know like you can't have it both
ways no no no right like
this man was clearly compromised you
demanded
that he come back he comes back he tears
his achilles can't do sports he mean
you know thank god he's come back
exceptionally well
congratulations to him a year later
imagine simone violes
comes on there she's not riding her head
she goes back out there
she does her thing injures herself break
her neck what you gonna say
you could have said no you [ __ ] ass
no these people these people these
people are lost
yo my god dude
dudes people are lost
and what i'm trying to tell you is if
you call up kevin durant quitter for not
going in there you're an idiot
because you saw what happened you saw
what no you saw what happened
he blew out his achilles but he still
came back
and blew out his achilles that's why
this is why i don't care too much for
public opinion because you got low iq
people
making all these loud comments about
stuff that they have no concept of
and this is the truth okay this is the
truth about athletics entertainment and
a lot of other fields
general even like employees of regular
jobs
these [ __ ] do not care about
you the customers generally don't care
about you
and guess who else doesn't care about
you the supervisors and the owners they
don't care about your well-being they
care about the bottom line
they want to get entertained they want
to get their product and then the other
end wants to make their money
so you have to prioritize your
well-being because none of these people
don't care
they don't care simone biles went
through all kinds of stuff
right she was she was touched against
her will
so were another 100 women by the same
u.s gymnastics team and she went on to
compete in the olympics and won all
those medals she went through all that
trial tribulation you imagine
being hurt by somebody for that long you
still go through it you do it come back
with the most gold medals ever won by
olympian
for gymnastics female and then you have
one year where you're like
i can't do it and like you're a quitter
despite going through all that
these people don't care about you they
don't they don't
i want to be entertained you offended my
politics
[ __ ] you that's that's how they operate
so
i would tell you fans don't care
organization nobody whether it's your
supervisor
whether it's your organization find
yourself a place that appreciates you
and actually cares about your well-being
and if they don't
prioritize yourselves at all costs never
never go out of your way to sacrifice
your health for other folks because they
don't care about you they will
run you through the grinder you die and
you know what happens
hr is putting in an application for
someone to fill your seat
oh but you you you didn't you weren't a
quitter you weren't a quitter but yeah
you did and nobody gonna take care of
your family
don't sacrifice don't sacrifice for
people that could
that could replace you that will replace
you within a week
if you didn't come what would you have
said if kevin durant had gone home
and the next snap would have been in
cancun or whatever
on his recovery y'all would have called
him a quitter
no i wouldn't have you might have that's
a stupid take if you're hurt
don't get on the field because then you
blow out your achilles you're hurt
you should go out there and if you don't
you're a bum
but if you get injured and your blade is
broken that's your problem
this is how stupid people are this is
how
dumb people are this is how
dumb people are you got ptsd get back in
the field and if you don't you're a
quitter
i dare someone to go say that to a
veteran
you're a quitter you got ptsd
get back in afghan that's tricky i don't
you you got you got yeah you got
i was triggered because i've seen how
this affects other people yeah
if you see it you're seeing it as one
thing playing the sports is another
thing
not playing and just you know doing your
lat ass
commentary for not knowing
i'm just so sick of people siding with
organizations and corporations and
echoing their sentiments it's just they
just ugh it's like all these people are
just ready to keep for these people who
don't give a [ __ ] about you this is
nasty
and this is how you know our society
does not acknowledge mental issues well
he thinks it's perfectly fine for you to
not go in
to work if your leg is busted
he thinks it's perfectly fine for you
not to go to war
if your leg is busted but if you got
ptsd
if you have mental health issues that
you can't function around people
get out there that's how stupid some of
these people are
so this is what i'm going to tell you
guys okay okay
because these people want to put your
life at risk so go [ __ ] themselves they
can go [ __ ] themselves imma tell you as
an individual
prioritize yourselves because you got
idiots like this in the public opinion
who are going to tell you to compromise
your health your well-being
for others and if you don't you're a
quitter you're shameful you're a
disgrace to this country
well listen any country that would throw
you under the bus
and put you through a grinder spit you
out and not consider your well-being
afterwards
isn't a country worth sacrificing
yourself for
you are bugging that's the low i this is
one of the dumbest things that
i just got triggered i got triggered oh
yeah you went on
man so many people are suffering so many
people are suffering i think people
think some some people think like
dude tough it up toughen up we came out
our whole anxiety [ __ ]
uh we came out of a whole anxiety
situation with kobe when people couldn't
train properly
and then you have this olympics come in
so a year before that you couldn't do it
she was probably good a year before
right but now we're postponing a year
after
after all this whole pandemic when
things are complicated
protocols mask tests then i remove your
medicine
then you have all this pass about you
getting touched then you have all this
pressure from the country
but you're a quitter and you win you
already have all the most medals
they can't take that [ __ ] away from you
but they trying wow
[ __ ] don't give a [ __ ] i'm
gonna say this people always say this
the people say oh people are soft now i
mean yeah
people are dealing with different
problems than they ever have in the
history of humanity
we're not fighting for our food we're
not fighting for our survival
we're not fighting for the same problems
we're not fighting russia right it's not
that many wars for us
so of course people are going to be bred
different and they're going to feel a
different type
of struggle now it's one of meeting
whereas the past people it's just like
make money and do it for your family now
it's a different time
so we're dealing with different sets of
struggles
that's the reality of the world you want
to say people are soft
the times are soft when's the last time
you had to pick up a gun and join the
draft huh
when's the last time you had to get in a
fist fight
most of you [ __ ] are not even
dealing with any kinds of dangers you're
soft like charmin you're not hard you're
not hard
i know it because every time i see a
dangerous video i got a bunch of retards
getting in the comments talking about
this is what i would do i'm a cap no you
wouldn't
because if you grew up around any danger
you would know [ __ ] better we got
more people today watching
anime [ __ ] watching sports and
playing sports
all of you guys are soft stop pretending
otherwise
the hardest experience that you have is
in the video game on the lowest setting
exactly stop yeah you guys got hero
complexes talking about what you would
do you wouldn't do [ __ ]
because you're soft but i want a medal
you don't want to deal with your own
inadequacy so you're like
oh no jesus you're soft i want to the
sooner a lot of you accept that
and the better it's going to be for you
you're soft
the world is soft soft there is no
dangers for you guys to face
but it's okay that it's soft because we
don't need it to be hard right now
yeah it's just it's what it is yeah even
if you won like whatever you want but
it's all in the game you're soft
but i want a first prize ech enforza
calm down calm down you drink the sani
okay
you don't have to walk for that [ __ ]
water and here's the thing
it's okay to be soft you're not your
parents generation you're not your
grandparents generation
stop pretending just because you go to
the gym doesn't make you hard
it doesn't you know how many times i see
buff dudes get slapped up
real quick they don't know what they're
doing stop pretending being big doesn't
make you big
so it's all this talk about like i'm oh
no you're not
your female counterparts are making way
more money than you you're soft people
are bred by their circumstances
and be grateful that you live today
because if you would have been living 60
years ago
being shafted and having sent to the
draft while rich people get to keep
their kids here
you probably wouldn't have felt so great
because you're probably gonna die in
world war ii
vast majority of you do you want to go
to vietnam
yeah you think those people who came
back from there they're glad to be hard
body most of them are [ __ ] up in the
head
mostly you're not bred for hard times
stop pretending
so embrace the times that we're in
embrace the struggles stop living the
[ __ ] past
[Music]
foreign